j'accueille maintenant sarah abitbol
comme votre bible et stéphane bernadis
mesdames messieurs
rarick dans le bon soir stéphane
bernadis bonsoir vice champion d'europe
et champion de france de patinage et le
2 février dernier vous êtes à salt lake
city pour les jeux olympiques d'hiver
vous entraînez tout va bien tout sauf
une vague douleur au tendon d'achille
pour sarah mais pas de quoi s'alarmer
soudain en tentant une triple boucle
piqué sarah ressent une vraie douleur et
le sou suivant sera fatale là vous
l'apporté jusqu'au vestiaire où elle
hurle en enlevant ses pattes à rupture
totale du tendon d'achille gauche
magnéto